[Música]
[Aplausos]
cuando era niña mi mejor amiga me sabía
a leche con anís
y ya se han de imaginar la primera vez
que le dije a mi mamá esto abrió los
ojos grandes y pestaño dos y me dice
agita chulo no me digas ketchup hasta tu
amiga
y no la verdad es que no había chupado a
mi amiga
pero pusiera su pelo
era su piel su tono de voz que a mí me
hacían sentir sabores
es que si ustedes se ponen a analizar un
poquito
la verdad es que los recreos eran bien
padres bien divertidos sabían a tutti
frutti
cuando yo escuchaba el agudo de una
canción era como exprimir el limón a tus
tacos
el jazz sabía como un sándwich de queso
derretido
y las rancheras no saben que sabían
insectos
la gente siempre se burlaba de mí crecí
y por un empezó a dar pena me daba miedo
imagínense decir todas estas cosas ya de
adolescente daba pena uno quería
pertenecer pues a un grupo que te
aceptaran
muchas veces la verdad es que me sentí
un poquito enferma
se sentía mucho y yo decía que me pasa
porque porque siento así porque pero no
decía nada me callaba no decía un día
decido ir con un neurólogo esto ya es de
adulta crezco estudio gastronomía y pues
la vida es difícil muy difícil pues
ustedes saben yo lo sé todos lo sabemos
y de grande de grande es bien complicado
muy difícil tienes muchas
responsabilidades hay que hacer mil
cosas
entonces yo pues me da insomnio no puedo
dormir
no puedo dormir de verdad terrible eso
realmente no se lo deseo a nadie ni al
peor enemigo jamás es horrible así que
decido ir con este neurólogo el qué
es un cliente del restaurante entonces
digo voy con él llegó le cuento la
receta pero se vuelve como una especie
de mi persona favorita
me pasa que hasta saco citas después
para para sentarme que me platiqué que
me cuenten más cosas
yo llegaba y le preguntaba y doctor la
verdad es que muy bien con mi
tratamiento pero cuénteme qué pasa
cuando la gente prueba y te dicen que
está rico qué pasa
cuénteme quiero saber
el doctor me contaba y entonces teníamos
de esta relación muy buena y un día me
atrevo y le cuento de mi padecimiento
pues ya saben la niña con leche con anís
y todo ese tema le cuento
y me dice
gaby tiene sinestesia
sinestesia sinestesia dios mío doctor
esa palabra se escucha el grave tengo
una enfermedad grave o sea si me
preocupé mucho mucho
sinestesia sinestesia se escuchaba como
algo de la cabeza algo me pasaba en la
cabeza algo era
entonces me empieza a platicar me dice
sinestesia a diferencia de anestesia
anestesia es cuando no tienes ninguna
sensación sinestesia es sentir demás
es cuando tus sentidos están conectados
cuando tienes una sensación
qué se siente intensa es muchas muchas
cosas muchas sensaciones por medio de un
único estímulo
todos los seres humanos todos al momento
de nacer
tenemos sinestesia pero a partir de los
6 meses
ocurre una poda neuronal se le llama
poda neuronal porque nuestras todas las
neuronas están conectadas entre sí
vueltas locas e imagines acabamos de
nacer entonces un bebé puede que cuando
escucha la voz de su mamá de un color
pero a partir de los 6 meses pues pasa
este proceso que les platico y resulta
que entonces se definen los sentidos y
tenemos ya todos los sentidos definidos
y entonces el oído el gusto el tacto
pero hay cierta gente que quedan todavía
estas conexiones entre sí y bueno
s sinestesia se dice que aproximadamente
un 4%
capaz de horita sale alguien aquí en el
público un 4% de la población humana
tienen sinestesia 3 por ciento de ellos
son mujeres 1% de ellos son hombres pero
muchas veces pues a como a mí me pasó te
callas porque te da pena o incluso
piensas que todo el mundo siente igual
que tiene lo mismo que tú entonces pavón
se te hace algo normal entonces ese 4%
probablemente y es un 8
si alguna vez no eso no le voy a decir
pero la sinestesia también se puede
pasar por una sinestesia se le puede
llamar sinestesia traumática que es
cuando alguien se da un golpe fuerte en
la cabeza y entonces ahí puedes
experimentar este tipo de sinestesia
pero hay otra que es esta sinestesia
temporal
qué es consumir cuando consume salud
algún hongo alucinógeno o algún ácido
ahí también puedes sentir está
esta experiencia de sinestesia y
entonces yo entendí por qué porque a mí
siempre toda la vida me han dicho hai y
gabi que te metiste
siempre desde chiquita gabi que te
metiste gad y que te formaste así
entonces yo bueno ahí entendí
después de que el doctor me dijo toda
esta explicación
evidentemente no me quedé con todo lo
que me dijo el doctor sino llegué a mi
casa y empecé a leer
y leer
y leer y leer y leer y pasaron meses
meses
hasta que vomité palabras de verdad las
vomité jaffé al baño abrelatas a vomité
no era comida no era nada eran palabras
fíjense que la sinestesia
es algo que a mí me hizo pensar cuando
entendí esto yo quería saber todo quería
saber quería saber si había más gente
que sentía lo mismo los quería conocer
entonces pues me di cuenta que habían
asociaciones de sinestesia alrededor del
mundo y los contacté les escribí a todos
quería saber qué les pasaba a ellos tú
qué sientes a ti qué te pasa y que
habían presidentes entonces le escribe
al presidente y yo dije bueno si no me
contesta
mi móvil no pasa nada me contestaron me
evitaban eventos yo iba yo escuchaba al
lado del presidente sentada pues me
atreví y lo hice me salió
eso me llevó a pensar que tenía que unir
mi profesión con mi padecimiento
o ni mi profesión con mi padecimiento
tenía que estar juntos entonces dije
claro se acuerdan de mi mamá la de los
ojos grandes mí me estudió música y
tenía una escuela de música para niños y
desde chica me la pasaba ahí
entonces decidí juntar esas dos cosas la
cocina con la música y dije claro
voy a cocinar canciones
sí sí sí sí porque no tengo sinestesia
entonces bueno me metí dije ahí voy dije
cómo voy a empezar
entonces empiezo a hacerlo y llegó la
primera vez práctico pam pam lo prueban
y dice ay no es que la chief se inspiren
canciones y yo no no no no no me inspiro
yo tengo sinestesia oído gustativa y los
sonidos me saben es diferente inspirarse
entonces en mi afán de que todos se
entendieran a qué me refería
pues dije no tengo que hacer como un
proceso creativo para que todos estemos
en sintonía y la gente que no tiene esta
condición pues también me entienda
porque si no va a hacer ese 4 por ciento
o sea quién sabe cómo cocinar una
canción primer paso vemos la procedencia
del artista de dónde es o qué estilo de
música toca
un artista que toca ritmos
latinoamericanos no le voy a poner
sabores de asia
entonces me voy a sabores tropicales
a cotto mis posibilidades para que no me
vaya con todos los sabores que existen
en el mundo entonces tengo ya algo más
definido
punto número 2 veo que se siente cuando
escuchar la canción
hay canciones que te hacen sentir feliz
y feliz hay canciones que te hacen
sentir triste triste que hasta lloras
horrible las ha pasado horas y horas la
música que acompaña en tus estados de
ánimo entonces para las canciones
felices decidimos ponerle una paleta de
sabores cuál es esa paleta de sabores
las canciones felices saben a cítricos
saben a frutas tropicales una cerveza
clara fría
te saben a un vinagre balsámico perdón
no balsámico a un vinagre blanco
todo fresco unos chiles verdes
las canciones tristes del otro lado
usted sabe na vinotinto a especias
animales de casa
a un whisky incluso un mezcal humo
pero también fíjense que hay canciones
bien raras bueno estilos de música que a
mí en lo particular me encantan como la
salsa la salsa vean ustedes hacen
combinaciones de dos es nostalgia esa
melancolía pero con garitas de bailar
con ganas de bailar si escuchas salsa y
es como yo no sé por qué razón cantarle
a ella si debía aborrecerla así si vives
qué locura qué locura y entonces ahí
pasa algo muy extraño
tienes una piña ganas de bailar de aquel
lado de la parte feliz pero esa piña
vean ustedes la vamos a poner al grill
y entonces agarran esa piña conmigo y
muerdan la
esa piña entonces
son estas ganas de bailar
con esa nostalgia con estas ganas de
bailar pero ahí no acabó todo yo decía
no no no es que ni modo en que yo llegué
con el artista y le expliqué todo mi
pergamino o sea a 80 horas entonces digo
no no no tengo que meterme más adentro
más rotundo más contundente
bueno pues los músicos ellos tienen
partituras
los músicos tienen partituras entonces
yo digo
voy a hacer una partitura gustativa como
lo una partitura gustativa inventamos
esta simbología
y les quise enseñar esta este este
dibujo porque es lo primerito que dibuje
cuando se me ocurrió esta es la más
genuina vean ahí el dibujo así de es
picuda la cidh es punta las ideas son
picos la acidez es un triángulo
si ustedes quieren hacer esa acidez no
tan pronunciada con una notita dulce o
algo así
y tiene sinestesia
me haces hasta la con tu mano me hiciste
así ahí está
y se siente mucho
entonces ahí está la no tan pronunciada
es más circular
si tenemos una estrella y una nube y
tenemos dos nombres bubba y kiki cuál es
cuál
chiquis la estrella bug es la nube todos
tenemos sinestesia de 4 estoy segura que
no es verdad
todos tenemos sinestesia entonces vean
vean mi favorita es el picante vean el
picante observan picante y ven que que
tiene como
todos estos punzantes de tintín pero a
la vez está esta espiral que es cuando
te enchiladas
no pica
entonces ahí dijimos claro
esos son mis símbolos esos son lo que yo
le voy a poner los artistas los músicos
leen notas pues yo tengo mi propio
símbolo donde yo me leo y yo me entiendo
entonces
sale la partitura gustativa este es un
ejemplo de la última partir de un bueno
no es la última es una de las últimas
que hemos hecho que es de miguel bosé
'morena mía' y bueno si se las sisi se
conectan conmigo vean la primera frase
que dice morena mía tenemos este círculo
sombreado y un círculo sin relleno y
luego tenemos este como gatito pero
ondeado todo esto significa algo y así
es como sacamos una partitura vamos
poniendo cosa por cosa morena mía voy a
contar hasta 10 y entonces se va 1 1 1 1
hasta finalizar la canción
cuando terminamos ahí están todo lo que
significa cada uno de los símbolos y
entonces sacamos la combinación
gustativa
qué es el dulce el dulce lo traducimos
con una fruta computada el salado
untuoso tiene su sabor luego el amargo
luego todo y entonces sale un plato y
entonces cuando cuando el artista
escucha la canción y la prueba y lee su
partitura pues imagínense se pone
contento se pone feliz
cuando ustedes
tengan una idea
tengan esa idea que no sea nada común
que esté fuera del entendimiento y la
gente les diga no no no te entiendo no
se callen que no les pase lo que a mí no
lo guarden no lo guarden no se lo que
ven pero si les tengo que dar un consejo
un consejo y por favor escuchen lo y
agarre lo que tienen que informar hay
que informarse hay que leer deben elegir
y leer y que no exista un libro o un
artículo que no hayan visto antes que no
la line de leído que nos digan ya lo leí
ya me lo sé
que no exista
que no exista porque una virtud vista
desde la ignorancia es el más grande de
los defectos si te da miedo si tienes
miedo ahí hay algo interesante y algo
bueno si la gente te dice que te metiste
que te metiste que te fumaste ahí hay
algo bueno hay algo muy bueno
un loco siempre va a estar loco
hasta que su idea no triunfe muchas
gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]